back in my study here
getting ready psychologically for my
trip
I'm going to be going to Denmark Sweden
and Poland two weeks I've been working
on my Danish and my polish uh I think my
comprehension is up how much I'll be
able to speak is a good question it
doesn't really matter I mean
realistically even if I get to speaking
fairly well which I won't then I'd lose
it again if I don't have you know the
chance to speak so often however uh I
can engage with a language I can improve
my comprehension
and it's very exciting to me just to see
how much I'll be able to understand when
I'm over there I have an advantage with
Danish in that I speak Swedish and of
course uh my abilities are to the extent
that I know Russian and and Ukrainian
and some Czech the Polish is that much
easier and I've spent some time on
polish as well so we'll see how I do I
will be reporting to you from my